hello everybody and welcome to part 12
of let's play from dust all right we got
ourselves here a little lava stream and
a little doohickey that looks it looks
like the repel water one except with
lava so I'm pretty sure that's gonna be
useful so let's try to divert the flow
here maybe oh I hope I didn't just
totally destroy my village by doing that
I probably did oh I probably did or
anyway nope nope we're cool
we're cool but I could destroy my
village very quickly Kanna kine it is
tempting oh oh whoa whoa hey oh no this
is bad that's very bad oh man oh [ __ ]
ah poop oh crap uh no guy I I it's all
right pick up the lava okay okay I can
do that I remember
go man go hurry cuz I have a feeling
we're all going to die in a few minutes
I have a very very good feeling about
that all right there's a repel water one
oh boy that village would be dead so
dead
these explody doohickeys boom boom bang
e oh man I feel bad for the people that
I'm gonna make go live there because I'm
not very competent at what I do I'm
pretty sure they're all gonna die all
right
I am benevolent I can protect people
from this all boy no I can't
that looks bad I look really really bad
oh no no no okay
are you rappelling yeah yeah take that
lava oh yeah
now what the hell do I do about it
where am I going home alright go guys go
oh man you guys are so dead I feel bad I
feel really bad I try to do something
amplify breath maybe if I try to keep it
from flowing like straight down the
mountain I'll probably help look I can
just Dam it up enough alright alright
just get one side of the mountain that
doesn't quite run straight into my
village that would be nice
and if I could find a way to carve out
like a a sort of River doohickey for de
lavaz no get on your sand I see lava
it's right there alright doesn't want me
to pick it up oh wait no I'm stupid I
just got the repelled lava thingy power
okay they're gonna be fine
I'm not worried about that
just in case though alright in the sake
that looks like the repel water one so
maybe they can have both oh oh you
better hurry guy
oh you Oh ma'am ma'am you need to hurry
up there's gonna be a an explosion of
lava in about 45 seconds
so I Becca I can't do much about it
ma'am madam sorry I fear that you may be
dead soon all right I think I got a
divert the flow of this one back the
other one anything okay all right um I
think I can use the yeah gimme gimme
back and I'm gonna poop boom uh-huh I'm
smart intelligent use of terraforming
Bangi huh no bang II oh you better bang
II come here bengi dammit why won't you
bang she bang she bang sorry to bring
that memory back you guys I couldn't
help it bang there we go okay no close
almost diverted ma Morse dirt not sand
dirt dirt okay
oh no oh no oh no oh no did you make it
Oh people stop trying it's okay you can
hold off oh now you're mixing the sounds
I like it yeah you're just gonna have to
wait man cuz that damn cuz I mean just
just damn says hold your horses
alright now the coolest thing about this
said I find lava just makes more land so
that is really cool yep alright now
there's also a river spring up here oh
that's another totem oh I did not see
that okay
alright it might be a bit of a prom
why'd you do that way it was a perfectly
good way that way oh man I do not
understand these people
Eric dumb dumber than dumb
what do you need help with what what oh
I see you're totally confused
alright that oh you're trying to give
the gift of water over there um well
that's just gonna have to wait because
water is the least of your concern right
now oh and you're trapped I feel bad
about you but not that bad alright this
one what power does it give me okay I
need to figure out how to get this one
up here ah got camera hey camera don't
that's with me camera I will back slap
you so fast hard yeah yeah that's right
okay I need to stop the flow there
so let me amplify the breathy here okay
get down oh did I get it yeah on the
first try
Oh block that stream up good alright
doesn't really answer how my people are
gonna get up there in the first place
but close oh hello
kaboom oh wow you are ingenuitive I got
to give you points for having the balls
to go around the rim of the volcano just
to try to deliver the power of repel
water to a town that is not ever gonna
need to repel water but still good for
you good for you
that last stretch you're on your own
without I'm still worried about trying
to figure out how to do this oh boy get
them guys oh all right okay I need to
help the water drain here let me amplify
the breath sploosh okay
no now get out there
uh-huh more little more little more okay
almost there man that is that could not
be in a worse place who chose that yeah
your water not sand dirt not dirt not
dirt dirt is the last thing I need
man I wish it another reason I wish it
wasn't up here biz because I can't turn
my camera down anything it's kind of in
a bad place but whatever I make do with
the situation I have suppose I could
have just evaporated it lava think I'll
do that
sploosh oh who needs my help once again
who needs my help
oh you you chose to go that way man I
did not make you go that way here go
down that way
and then be logical about it whatever
okay I'm gonna build a ramp up to the
next area
cuz it just happened to be in the worst
spot possible but uh I'm gonna make do
okay all right nice little ramp can they
make it I don't know who knows
try try guys go man go
oh wow they're gonna do it but yeah
you're not gonna make it that way so
don't try you're gonna try anyway aren't
you just go that way the nice path I've
made for you it's right there it's right
there guys there you go that's more like
it
okay good good job all right uh where's
the where's the portal out of here I
don't even know Oh
kaboom yeah is it just me I don't see a
portal out oh wait what hello hello can
get this thing
yeah you trapped up here with nothing
else to do you might as well be useful
Oh No you are so gonna die oh I'm so
sorry oh I'm so sorry your oh you made a
bad choice oh boy
sorry ma'am well maybe maybe you're
gonna be fine who knows wow that would
be something to see good job lady you're
fine you're fine okay alright got this
here I'm here
do your thing there we go
okay another story now I don't know
where to go oh they're right there how
long has that been there oh that's new
shut up stream I want you to be here
wait a minute what the hell weird all
this water come from that is new oh boy
oh that's why everyone needed the repel
water oh no oh no people are gonna die
oh that person I feel bad I'm sorry
Oh ma'am you survived a volcano only to
be washed into the ocean I'm sorry I
can't
it's not like black and white I can't
pick people up okay man you are a
survivor oh [ __ ] caca Oh jellify water
please oh man and fly the breath I lost
I lost a village I just lost it
some village I just lost oh that's great
nature's returning but people are dying
oh boy
doo-doo-doo-doo sorry sorry beeps oh man
ah [ __ ] can I get out of here oh yes I
can
Oh this island is screwed I feel bad
okay the animals are back just in time
to die okay bye bye hi everyone else
sorry about you know being drowned and
then burned alive it's a real shame but
I'm moving on
yep cuz I'm the but never let god I am
alright where am I now how many people
are gonna die this map everybody you say
I'll save at least one maybe that lady
over there yeah that's a good name for
an island DC ow
Leonie Dada Dada Baracus ah Don Osama
new merica diva cinemas my dacha a pas
de teba tada
I think you're to understand that
they're all dead
because they made these poor choices
alright anyway I have to cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in part 13 of let's play
from dust Baba Oh